Speaker 1: Okay. We are taking calls through
discord. Remember, if you want even a chance
of getting on, your nickname has to have your
name and where you're calling in from. So I see
folks with nicknames or no location or, you know,
inside jokes or whatever. You won't get called
on unless you have the proper delineation. Like,
for example, Jess from Oregon. Jess from Oregon,
you were able to figure out how to correctly set
up your nickname, and now you're on the show.
Speaker 2: Wonderful. I wanted to ask you about
the have you seen these environmental protests
like environmental protesters who have been
throwing food on paintings and then gluing
their hand to the wall?
Speaker 1: Yes, I have.
Speaker 2: Okay. My question for you is,
as you know, we're we're both pretty young
people who care about the earth. Does this do
anything? Is this giving attention to is this
like calling attention to the right people?
Speaker 1: Is this. I don't think so. Just
I think that this is a terribly misguided form of
protest. Now, one of the arguments that's made is.
But listen, David, now you and Jess are talking
about it. Yes, we're talking about it. But the
context isn't that the attempted destruction of a
Van Gogh painting has now made. Jess and I start
donating to End World Hunger. Right. We're talking
about it as, wow, this is really misguided. Now,
I am sympathetic to the view that if you only
do protests in the ways that everybody agrees
you should do them, you will achieve nothing
in many cases. It's understood that sometimes
you've got to make people a little uncomfortable
or you've got to kind of insert yourself into a
situation. But destroying artwork, priceless
artwork, historically significant artwork to
make the case that we should be focused
on the climate or on hunger or whatever,
I don't think is actually achieving that. And
if you look at the conversations about these
attempts to, you know, throw the paint and
all this other stuff, it's mentioned that,
oh, and it was because of hunger, but nobody
goes, Wow, that's really what our focus should
be. Let's go donate to end hunger. People
go, This is the wrong way to go about it.
The motivation becomes not even secondary. It
becomes almost irrelevant. And they're I don't
believe they're achieving anything at all.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think it's it's it's I'm
sorry. It is creating a spectacle instead
of creating something thought provoking.
Speaker 1: Right. Right.
Speaker 2: All right. Well,
thank you very much for your input.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Jess. Everything
good in Oregon there?
Speaker 2: No, it's I mean,
it's smoky, but the smoke.
Speaker 1: All right. Well,
appreciate hearing from you.
Speaker 2: Thanks so.
Speaker 1: Much. All right. There goes Jess
from Oregon, bringing up a very important issue.